the UK consists of England Wales
Northern Ireland and Scotland where
residents will soon vote on whether they
should remain in this United Kingdom or
break away to form an independent
Scotland for the first time in more than
300 years but the Scots English Welsh
and Northern Irish share more than a
history and a monarchy they also share a
currency so what would happen to the
british pound if Great Britain got a
little smaller pro-independence leader
Alex Salmond says an independent
scottish government would follow expert
counsel and keep the pound the
multi-party group of politicians who
oppose independence say a Scotland that
leaves loses the pound automatically the
pound sterling doesn't belong to anyone
as the individual countries the United
Kingdom it belongs to the United Kingdom
as a whole Scottish nationalists call
this an empty threat because a currency
breakup with damaged economies on both
sides of the border while a currency
union they say would benefit the two new
nations under such an arrangement fiscal
rules and financial oversight might need
negotiating and according to the bank of
england which right now is confusingly
the bank for the whole united kingdom
such rules could impact an independent
Scotland a currency union is
incompatible with sovereignty but forget
politicians and policy experts the polls
say that most ordinary Brits outside
scotland say the scotch should lose the
power of the pound there's another
intriguing option with a fully tradable
currency like the Sterling the Scots
could simply use it without UK consent
just like Panama spends a u.s. dollar
without America's see so